(intense music)
(clock ticking)
- [Voiceover] Into the
final seconds of the game.
Buffalo has the ball.
Fumble!
(crowd roars)
It's a fumble, I can't believe it!
(driving music)
(crowd cheering)
Herman Edwards runs it down the field.
- [Voiceover] Manning
and the pressure from the
Patriots' defense, but gets out!
He throws it way down the field!
(audience cheering)
What a catch!
David Tyree makes the catch!
- [Voiceover] This is the
Steelers final chance.
Bradshaw makes the throw.
It's incomplete.
No, wait,
Franco Harris has the ball!
(audience roars)
Touchdown, Steelers!
- [Voiceover] Montana moves right.
He throws.
(spectators cheering)
Clark catches it, touchdown!
The crowd is going crazy!
(music intensifies)
(brutish grunting)